zur Situation es ist grauenhaft dass es
eines Krieges bedürfte der schon vor
langem angefangen hat um das größte Land
in Europa in unsere in unseren
Wahrnehmungshorizont überhaupt
aufzunehmen
es bedurfte eines Krieges um zu lernen
dass es Städte gibt Odessa cherchiv
mariupold Kiew des bedurfte der
Zerstörung es bedürfte der Bomben es
bedürft eine Flüchtlingsbewegung die
zwischen ein Viertel der Bevölkerung
außer Landes getrieben hat um damit die
Europäer und die deutschen lernen dass
es außerhalb Russlands noch etwas
anderes gibt ein Land das nicht auf
unsere inneren Landkarte war und die
Frage ist wie kommt es eigentlich dass
es in Deutschland
keinen Raum gegeben hat für dieses große
und jetzt in Bedrängnis elementare
Bedrängnis geratene Land das hat etwas
mit einer
totalen Fixierung auf Russland zu tun
die man gut erklären kann es gibt
historische Beziehungen es gibt die
Beziehung der Dynastien es gibt
kulturelle Beziehungen über Jahrhunderte
es gibt die große russische Literatur
die Kunst es gibt die grauenhafte
Erfahrung der beiden Völker der
deutschen der Russen in dem furchtbaren
Krieg in dem die Deutschen so viel
angerichtet haben aber Sie haben nicht
nur etwas in Russland angerichtet
sondern auf dem Territorium der
Sowjetunion und das heißt die
Hauptschauplätze des Krieges waren wir
Larus und das war war die Ukraine und
die Frage ist wie kommt es eigentlich
dass die Deutschen so ausschließlich auf
Russland fixiert sind und das hat etwas
mit
Faszination für dieses große Land und
dieses reichen Land zu tun und es hat
etwas mit auch mit Schrecken und Angst
zu tun und zwischen diesen pendelt
eigentlich die deutschen Wahrnehmung
unentwegt und
heraus und es kommt noch viele Dinge
hinzu die Dankbarkeit das Gorbatschow
den der deutschen Wiedervereinigung
nicht im Weg gestanden hat sondern sie
befördert hat aber die Frage ist ob ihr
verstanden haben wie dieses Russland
nach dem Ende der Sowjetunion wirklich
tickt und ich glaube das ist eine
Wahrnehmung gibt die in gewisser Weise
von eingehüllt ist in in
Sentimentalitäten in
die Erinnerung von verschiedenen
Generationen auch von Ahnungslosigkeit
also die Generation meine Generation in
der Regel die ist nie nach Russland
Gefahren in osloh war das etwas anders
es gibt eigentlich keine große Kenntnis
des Landes und wie wie tickt ist und ich
glaube wir haben nun viel zu lange und
damit beschäftigt zu erklären dass der
Westen und die NATO schuld sein dass es
jetzt so in Russland gekommen ist und
das ist ein unglaublich bequemes und
einfaches Modell die Wahrheit ist man
muss sich erklären wie ein großes Land
nach dem Ende des Imperiums eine neue
Rolle findet und sich neu aufstellt und
diese Führung die putinische Führung hat
es nicht vermocht und er ist ein Fehling
man in gewisser Weise er hat es nicht
vermocht das Land aufzustellen für die
Modernisierung des Landes für eine
moderne Nationsbildung für eine für das
21 Jahrhundert sondern er hat den
einfachsten Weg gewählt der einfachste
Weg war Gas zu liefern Öl zu liefern
jetzt Getreide zu klauen und zu liefern
und jetzt sogar noch Menschen Menschen
sich anzueignen Manpower durch
Vertreibung durch Umsiedlung durch
Umvolkung und so weiter und diese
die Dynamik eines eines Landes dem das
Reich abhanden gekommen ist zu verstehen
und die ungeheure Destruktivität die
darin besteht wenn es keinen Ausweg
gefunden hat und Putin hat das Land in
die Sackgasse geführt und das die
Tragödie ist das Russland bis heute sich
in diese Sackgasse hat führen lassen was
ein eigenes Thema ist warum ist und
warum es soweit wir hatten wir einmal
Herrn Fahrt Fragen ja haben wir uns in
Russland getäuscht oder wie es auch war
hatten wir gar keine Ahnung von dem Land
ich glaube schon dass wir Russland immer
richtig eingeschätzt haben auch in der
Vergangenheit ich meine ich muss auch
sagen bei den Energielieferungen in
Russland das Frau Merkels Kurs richtig
war ja natürlich für halten immer noch
für richtig mir fehlt einfach
deswegen überhaupt nicht dass das sage
ich aus Überzeugung wie es gibt in dem
Krieg so wie er jetzt abläuft einfach
keine militärische Lösung das ist der
Punkt und das wird einfach hier
übersehen in der Debatte wir haben eine
1200 km lange Frontlinie von Charkov im
Norden bis nach Carson das läuft da ab
da liegen sich die Parteien gegenüber
die Ukraine werden auch in Zukunft immer
begrenzte offensiven militärische
offensiven durchführen können weil sie
die amerikanischen Aufklärungsdaten
haben die Russen können quasi operativ
taktisch keine Überraschung
hierherstellen das geht nicht aufgrund
der westlichen Hilfe das ist ja auch
richtig so das ist alles in Ordnung aber
da wird keine Bewegung entstehen was wir
jetzt haben werden ist nach den Schein
Referenden eben ein stärkeren
Guerillakrieg im dombas nicht in den
feindlichen Linien und das wird
sicherlich jetzt das Thema der nächsten
Monate sein wenn wir das weiter
alimentieren militärisch das wollen wir
ja der Westen dann wird das ein langer
abnutzungskrieg und dann kann man am
Ende sagen jawohl militärisch
erfolgreich am Ende könnt ihr die
Ukraine sein so erfolgreich wie die
Taliban nach 20 Jahren
westlicher Truppen oder die mutscheredin
in Afghanistan als die Sowjets dann doch
nach acht Jahren abziehen mussten oder
die Amerikaner wegen der wird kommen
nicht also ich sag mal so eine
erfolgsmöglichkeit gibt es aber der
große Unterschied ist eben Russland ist
nicht Afghanistan Russland ist nicht
Libyen Russland ist nicht Irak nicht
Russland ist an atommarkt
eben es geht es geht ab einfach nicht
sie sind eine nuklear macht sie sind die
stärksten nuklearme der Welt das heißt
wenn Sie in diesem Spektrum unterwegs
sind militärisch stehen sie immer vor
der Möglichkeit des Umschlags in ein
allgemeinen dritten weltkriegt
man soll diesen Bluff ernst nehmen das
ist
tatsächlich so nicht und das muss man
ernst nehmen das kann man nicht einfach
sagen auch der läuft doch nur ich muss
sagen
also wenn ich wenn ich sehe zum Beispiel
unsere ja also das muss ich auch
fairerweise sagen das Bundeskanzleramt
in dem Fall aber zum Beispiel ist da
sehr gesund sein und vorsichtig und und
versucht da im Grunde genommen
einerseits Waffenlieferungen ja aber
eben doch so moderat dass es immer noch
uns Scholz ist auch der einzige der noch
von diplomatischen Lösungsweg vor allem
auch von vielen Bundestagsabgeordneten
die twittern dann alles für die Ukraine
die Ukraine muss den Krieg gewinnen ich
würde nicht sagen oder würden Sie sagen
dass im Bundestag alle sagen Herr Scholz
macht einen guten Job und lieben diese
Besonderheit mir kommt es eher so vor in
der Berichterstattung dass viele auch
mit Herrn Scholz hadern wegen seiner
Besonderheit in der Sache oder würden
Sie nicht zustimmen ich glaube die
mediale Aufgeregtheit die wir oft
erleben bringt er auch manche zu Unrecht
in Verdacht ich erlebe herr Scholz als
sehr besonnen und würde mal ein bisschen
anderen Blick darauf werfen auf dem Land
Russland dem die Leute weglaufen es geht
ja hier um einen Krieg auch gegen Werte
gegen Werte die die Ukraine sich
erarbeitet ja erwirtschaftet hat im
Laufe der Jahre um Frieden Freiheit und
auch Wohlstand in einem sozialen
marktwirtschaftlichen System auf das sie
sich einlassen wollten die Ukraine und
das das glaube ich auch dass man diesen
Weg beschreiten wollte und jetzt haben
wir eine Situation in der Friede und
Freiheit in Europa wieder angegriffen
werden und tatsächlich in ein System
also wo kommen wir denn dahin wenn jeder
hier jeden wieder annektieren kann wie
das irgendwann vor vor
Jahrhunderten der Fall war also ich
glaube hier auch mal einen Strich zu
ziehen und sagen dieses Land ist eben
nicht erfolgreich mit seiner
Lösungsvorschlag Frau Konrad ist eben
nicht erfolgreich mit seiner Strategie
die es gerade fährt weil ihm die jungen
Männer jetzt weglaufen weil die Leute
das auch nicht mehr mitmachen im Land
weil natürlich auch ein
Wohlstandsverlust was
einhergeht müssen wir hier auch weiter
dabei der Linie bleiben und die Ukraine
in jedem Fall unterstützen
sagen ja was ist denn gesagt die Ukraine
muss in jedem Fall weiter auch
unterstützt werden das ist der Weg den
die Bundesrepublik eingeschlagen hat und
der auch weiter verfolgt wird und wie
gesagt Sie haben sie haben ja eben Herr
Schlögl sehr schön auch die die
historischen Zusammenhänge
herausgearbeitet und ich glaube das ist
wirklich eine ganz ganz schwierige
Situation in Bezug auf den energiekrieg
den wir jetzt vor der eigenen Haustür
erleben und den wir lösen müssen die
Lösung ist wir müssen unsere eigenen
Hausaufgaben jetzt viel schneller machen
und tatsächlich die Krisen hier auch in
unserem eigenen Land bewältigen und
Lösungen finden so dass unser eigenes so
dass die Bevölkerung hier auch auch also
das ist nochmal ganz klar wir haben ja
alle Konsens das selbst Angriff
überhaupt nicht okay war da haben wir
glaube ich alle Konsens ist aber ganz
darüber zu betonen
ihr würde sich schon sehen wie es weil
sie gerade wir müssen jetzt zu gewinnen
und es hat so aus es ist natürlich
Putin hat ja durchaus ein paar Trümpfe
in der Hand und jetzt kann man sagen
militärisch spielt ist es nicht gut
gelaufen militärisch
korrigieren militärisch ist ja unter
Druck hat im Prinzip immer noch dieses
druckpotenzial mit einem Atomwaffen aber
auf der anderen Seite die Zeit spielt
auch für ihn mit der Bereitschaft der
europäischen Bevölkerung weiter Kurs zu
halten und wenn er jetzt die
Energiekrise sich verschärft wenn wir
wirtschaftliche Probleme kommen dann
kriegen dieses Jahr nicht Rezessionen in
Europa das ist halt Seiten alle
Institute auch weltweit dann kommt der
Druck immer mehr und deshalb ist es
natürlich so wenn wir wirklich sagen wir
sind hier in diesem Konflikt im großen
Konflikt mit Russland und wir wollen
Putin Schwächen dann müssen wir eben ich
habe mich jetzt da die Energiepreise
weltweit runter kriegen und das muss die
Priorität sein und wenn wir das nicht
machen wenn ihr Energiepreise hoch
bleiben wird die Unzufriedenheit wachsen
es kann man sagen okay in Deutschland
wird es dann so interessiert das dann
die die auf die Straße gehen die werden
dann gleich
kritisiert aber ich glaube europaweit
wird es schwierig